All right, we left
off at number 11.
This is a pretty straightforward
triangle.
So I can draw it in my messy
style, without the line tool.
We have A, B, C.
This is 3, 4, and 6.
Each angle of triangle ABC has
the same measure as an angle
in triangle XYZ, which
has not been shown.
Well, we should draw
that, though.
It has the same angle.
I have a feeling that this is
a similar triangle X, Y, Z.
XYZ.
If the length of one side of
XYZ is 24-- so we just know
some random side here is 24.
it could be this one.
Maybe, I don't know.
If the length of one side is
24, what is the possible
perimeter of XYZ?
What is one possible
perimeter?
This probably has three correct
answers, which is fun,
because in some ways, increases
your probability of
getting this right.
But when you know that two
triangles have all the same
angles, you immediately know
that it is a similar triangle.
Which means that they look the
same, they're just of a
different scale.
And you should watch the similar
triangle video that I
made in the geometry
play list, if this
makes no sense to you.
Because this will make no sense
if you haven't heard the
term before.
But, since these are similar
triangles, the ratios of the
corresponding sides are
going to be the same.
They're letting us pick which
side has a length of 24.
So let's say that the side that
corresponds to side 3 is
of length of 24, right?
We don't know that this is
definitely the case, but
they're letting us pick.
So I'm going to say that
X Y corresponds to A B.
So if this side is 24, then this
side is going to be 4/3
of this side, right?
Hopefully, you remember similar
triangles, that the
ratios of the sides
are the same.
So if 3 is to 4, as 24 is to--
Well, to go from 3 to 24, we
multiply by 8.
So to go from 4 to this,
we multiply by 8.
So 32.
And to go from 6 to this,
we multiply by 8.
48.
So this is a possible
combination of sides for a
similar triangle to
triangle ABC.
And we can just add these up.
So 24 plus 32 is 56.
Plus 48.
6 plus 8 is 14.
104.
Just bubble type that in, 104.
This could have been 24.
If this is 24, that means
we're multiplying
by 6 to get to 24.
So this would be 18.
This would be 36.
You could add all of
those up together.
And you would have gotten
another answer.
And that would have
been correct.
And similarly, you could
have made this side 24.
If this side was 24, then that
means we're multiplying
every side by 4.
So this would have been 12, and
this would have been 16.
And you could have
added those up.
And that would have been the
other, the third possible,
correct answer for
this problem.
Exciting.
Let's move on.
The sum of five consecutive
integers is a thousand.
Number 12.
If five consecutive integers
is a thousand, what is the
value of the greatest
of these integers?
So they're consecutive
integers.
So there are five of them.
So we want to know the greatest
of these integers.
So let's say x is the greatest.
And so the second
greatest is going
to be x minus 1.
The third greatest
is x minus 2.
The fourth greatest
is x minus 3.
And then the fifth greatest
is x minus 4, right?
These are five integers and
they're consecutive.
And this is the largest,
right?
And we're going to take
the sum of them.
This is a tip.
If they were asking for the
smallest number, I would have
started with x.
And I would have gone, x
plus one, x plus 2, x
plus 3, like that.
Because then x would have
been my smallest number.
But they said x is the largest.
We want to solve for
x, so the greatest of
these integers.
So that's why I subtracted.
If we add all these
up, we have 5 x's.
So that's 5x minus 1
minus 2 is minus 3.
Minus 3 is minus 6.
Minus 4 is minus 10.
5x minus 10.
They say that the
sum is 1,000.
And this is a fairly simple
algebra equation.
5x is equal to-- add
10 to both sides.
1,010, which is also 10 in
binary, if you are a geek.
Divide both sides by 5. x
is equal to 205, right?
No, I can't divide by 5.
202, right?
x is equal to 202.
There you go.
Not too bad.
All right.
Number 13.
And I'm going to switch colors,
because pale yellow is
getting monotonous.
I'll switch to something
bold like blood red.
No, that's tacky.
Number 13.
The figure above shows
y equals g of x.
So let me draw that, because I
don't want to confuse you just
saying a lot of random crap.
You see what the graph looks
like, although you should have
it turned to the same page.
OK.
I draw it like that.
No, I don't have to draw
that far down.
Like that.
And it looks something
like this.
Let me draw it in a
different color.
The line itself-- something
goes from here,
goes up like this.
Then, it kind of comes
back down like here.
Then it kind of bounces.
It goes back up like this.
And then they tell us that this
line, right here, is y is
equal to g of x.
It's going to be a functions
problem.
I can tell you already.
So you should watch the function
videos or do the
function modules on
Khan Academy.
So the figure above shows the
graph y equals g of x.
If the function h is defined by,
h of x is equal to g of 2x
plus 2, they want to know
what h of 1 is equal to.
Well, with functions,
they're putting a 1
into this black box.
So wherever we see the x,
we put a 1 in, right?
So h of 1 is equal to-- let's
just use this definition-- g
of 2 times x.
Well, in this case, x is 1.
g of 2 times 1 plus 2.
So that equals g of 3 plus 2.
Now, we have to figure
out what g of 3 is.
And if you look at this graph--
and in the book it's
more obvious.
There's 1, 2, and then it hits
0 right at 3, right?
So g of 3, when x is equal to
3, g of 3 is right here.
That's 0.
g of 3 is 0.
We're just left with a 2.
h of 1 is 2.
That's all.
Amazing.
All right, next problem.
Number 14.
Exactly 4 actors try out
for 4 parts in a play.
If each actor can perform any
1 part, and no one will
perform more than 1 part, how
many different assignments of
actors are possible?
Well, let's just say you're just
randomly doing it, right?
So let's put up the actors.
You take the first guy, right?
And you say, well, I
can put him in any
1 of 4 roles, right?
For the first guy, I could
put him in any
1 of 4 roles, right?
And then the second guy-- I
shouldn't assume they're all
men-- and the second actor,
or woman, or actress.
1 role has been taken
already, right?
There were 4 roles.
This first person took it.
So now, there's only 3
roles left, right?
There's 3 possibilities.
There's 1 of 3 possibilities
for that
second person, correct?
OK, so the third person-- how
many possibilities does he or
she have left?
Well, 2 of the roles have
been taken already.
So there's only 2 possibilities
for that person.
And then the last person
to be picked has only
1 role left, right?
So the combinations are
literally just 4 times 3
times 2 times 1.
So that's 12 times 2.
That's 24 combinations or
assignments of roles.
And I actually haven't made a
probability, and combinations,
and permutations video yet.
I will.
And once I do, watch that
if this problem seemed
confusing to you.
But hopefully, it makes a little
bit of intuitive sense.
I'll see you in the
next video.